sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder dem des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gerollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und schiffe nicht gefahren
im krieg geht es um menschen
mit
oder ohne uniform
[Musik]
menschen in städten
dörfern
welt an
verbündete fremde
[Musik]
verfeindeten nachbarn
hunderte millionen menschen
die sechs jahre und einen tag lang
die hölle auf erde durchlebten
[Musik]
1942 der krieg geht in sein drittes jahr
binnen weniger monate haben das deutsche
reich und japan riesige gebiete erobert
gekämpft wird in osteuropa in nordafrika
und im pazifikraum
noch vor jahresende wird sich der
verlauf des krieges an jedem dieser
schauplätze dramatisch verändern
aus vormarsch wert rückzug aus siegern
werden verlierer aber die gewalt
bestimmt weiter das leben von millionen
menschen
[Musik]
am 9 september 1940 waren italienische
truppen ins britisch besetzten ägypten
eingefallen
erst im dezember starteten die briten
eine gegenoffensive
mit durchschlagendem erfolg
150 stunden haben unsere fans trotzdem
italien zustellungen durchbrachen die
diesen die versuchten viel aber rang zu
halten sind abgeschnitten bei diesem
vorstoß in die westliche wüste errangen
foto truppen einen klaren sieg dieser
daten des dusche einheimische und
italiener sind auf trab
[Musik]
anfang januar 1941 hatte hitler pläne
zur unterstützung italiens angekündigt
er ernannte general erwin rommel zur
befehlshaber der deutschen
unterstützungstruppen aus denen später
das deutsche afrika korps hervorgehen
wird
[Musik]
libysche politiker mit
führungsqualitäten waren immer
gegenstand von debatten und gleichzeitig
ein großer mythos
am 11 februar 1941 landeten die ersten
deutschen truppen
ende märz befahl rummel den angriff und
drängte die britischen truppen 800
kilometer weit zurück
am 15 juni 1941 startete
oberbefehlshaber archie broadway will
die alliierte gegenoffensive operation
battle axe ziel die befreiung der
belagerten stadt tobruk nur drei tage
später telegrafierte way will der
britischen regierung ich bedaure das
scheitern von battle axe mitzuteilen
virgil sagte damals rommel hat die neu
gewonnenen lorbeeren von ravens stirn
gerissen und in den sand geworfen
turkcell versetzte level kurzerhand nach
indien
oberstleutnant heinz schmidt berichtet
vom jubel auf seiten der achsenmächte
überall wo er hinkam strahlten ihn die
truppen an er war auf dem besten weg ein
held zu werden
ein geschenk befindet und ein gefundenes
fressen für seine propaganda
am 21 januar 1942 startet rommel die
gegenoffensive
am 29 januar erobern die achsenmächte
bengasi zurück
am dritten februar erreicht dass afrika
korps schließlich das dorf al tamimi
etwa 100 kilometer westlich von tobruk
mit manchen der ortsnamen können viele
der männer die hier kämpfen nicht viel
anfangen
[Musik]
die namen sagten uns wenig
was würden sie sich darunter vorstellen
gar nichts es ist nur ein name
rommel hatte geplant die alliierte
verteidigungslinie die gaza linie
südlich zu umfahren
doch seine truppen werden eingekesselt
der gefreite claude valentyn kämpft auf
seiten der alliierten ich entdeckte zwei
panzer etwa 1500 meter vor uns wir
hielten an und ich wurde misstrauisch
als ich mündungsfeuer sei gefolgt von
einer granate die etwa 20 meter neben
uns einschlug wir rasten los als keine
deutschen mehr zu sehen waren musste ich
mich erst mal sammeln und bat cutler
meine whiskey flasche rauszuholen wir
tranken alle einem kleinen schluck
aber rummels panzerarmee schafft es
auszubrechen am 18 juni stehen seine
truppen vor tobruk zwei tage später
erobern sie die hafenstadt und rommel
wollte tobruk einnehmen um nachschub auf
dem seeweg bekommen zu können außerdem
konnte er ägypten von dort aus leichter
angreifen
nach dem fall von tobruk bringen
konservative abgeordnete im britischen
unterhaus einen misstrauensantrag gegen
die regierung ein
einer von ihnen erklärt
dieses parlament zollt dem heldentum und
der ausdauer der königlichen
streitkräfte anerkennung hat aber kein
vertrauen in die übergeordnete strategie
ramos lake city jail hommels image als
super general diente in gewisser weise
als entschuldigung für die britischen
streitkräfte warum werden wir besiegt
weil wir gegen einen übermenschen
kämpfen tag nicht weil unsere taktik
schlecht ist unsere ausrüstung schlecht
ist und unsere führung die sache nicht
im griff hat
allerdings ist der hafen von tobruk zu
klein um ihn als basis nutzen zu können
das erschöpfte afrika korps marschiert
weiter nach ägypten bis nach el alamein
100 kilometer vor alexandria ein
stabsoffizier schreibt über die erste
schlacht von el alamein
auf dem papier schienen wir die schlacht
gewonnen zu haben aber der preis war zu
hoch die panzer gruppe war verschlissen
es wurde bald klar dass nur noch einen
weg übrig blieb ein allgemeiner rückzug
aus der kyrenaika
der flugplatz wird immer größer es gibt
immer mehr akteure und vermutlich noch
viele akteure bis diese tragödie beendet
ist
[Musik]
am 13 august übernimmt lieutenant
general bernard montgomery das kommando
über die achte armee den meisten
soldaten bedeutet das allerdings relativ
wenig erinnert sich jackpot damals
leutnants bei der britischen armee
es war uns völlig egal wer das kommando
hatte alles was wir wollten war
fronturlaub in kairo wir lebten von tag
zu tag wer an den hebeln der macht sei
es interessiert uns nicht
an seinem ersten tag als befehlshaber
konfrontiert montgomery generalstabschef
freddy quinn gott
mein freund ihr jungs scheint hier ein
ziemliches durcheinander angerichtet zu
haben
ein eigenwilliger typ trug nicht die
vorgeschriebene uniform er hatte einen
komischen akzent er war ein typ den
viele soldaten ins herz schlossen fast
wie ein maskottchen
hohmeister montgomery wartet auf den
richtigen moment dann in der nacht vom
auf den 24 oktober startet er eine
großoffensive gegen rommels panzerarmee
afrika die zweite schlacht von el
alamein beginnt mit massivem
artilleriebeschuss
natürlich wurde auch leuchtkugel
munition eingesetzt die nacht wurde zum
tag die google nur so durch die luft ich
aber wir machten einfach immer weiter
hätten wir uns bei jedem pfeifen auf den
boden geschmissen wären wir gar nicht
mehr hochgekommen
[Musik]
ich stand neben unserem zug offizier und
er sagte zu mir
wir werden diesen krieg gewinnen
privacy gatwick goldsucher in
westaustralien
briefe tier an einen freund in port
hedland schrieb sind erhalten geblieben
endlich hörst du von mir altes haus tut
mir leid dass ich nicht früher
geschrieben habe aber was das schreiben
angeht ist der krieg wie der dschungel
für seinen einsatz im gefecht wird
gatwick ausgezeichnet ein augenzeuge
berichtet plötzlich ohne vorwarnung zu
percy eine granate heraus stand auf und
rannte vorwärts sein gewehr in der
linken hand es war verrückt er war so
schnell dass die deutschen gar nicht
merkten wie ihnen geschah
patrick wird getötet
eine woche zuvor hatte er seinen
vierzigsten geburtstag gefeiert
es ist eine schlacht in der tausende von
männern weit weg von ihrer heimat um
ihre leben kämpfen
am 29 oktober schreibt rommel seiner
frau ich habe nicht mehr viel hoffnung
nachts liege ich mit offenen augen und
kann nicht schlafen wenn ich an die last
denke die auf meinen schultern legt
intensivem der große rummel mythos
entstand kurioserweise größtenteils auf
britischer seite auf sie bewunderten ihn
weil er sich ständig besiegt und in dili
vor allem in der wüste
viele deutsche dagegen vertraten die
ansicht trommelte ein übersetzter
kommandeur der leichtfertig mit dem
leben seiner männer umging und keine
ahnung von logistik hatte
100.000 deutsche und italienische
soldaten stehen
230.000 alliierten gegenüber
am ersten und zweiten november
entwickelt sich eine heftige
panzerschlacht diese gewinnen
montgomerys männer denen mehr als
doppelt so viele panzer zur verfügung
stehen das afrika korps ist so gut wie
geschlagen des schicksals hat der
zweiten schlacht von el alamein waren
die alliierten strategisch gesehen in
der offensive wie defensive
am dritten november hat rommel nur noch
30 höchstens 35 funktionsfähige panzer
er will den rückzug antreten um nicht in
die hände der briten zu geraten dafür
erbittet er handlungsfreiheit
am selben tag erhält rommel eine
nachricht von hitler in der situation in
der sie sich befinden gibt es keinen
anderen gedanken als standhaft zu
bleiben keinen meter boden nachzugeben
und jede waffe und jeden mann in die
schlacht zu werfen ihren truppen können
sie keinen anderen weg zeigen als den
zum sieg oder zum tod
die anfragen sich gerne 100 wiederholen
darf ein deutscher panzer wird
ausgeschaltet ein überlebender ergibt
sich und unsere jungs machten weggabe
am vierten november ordnet rommel den
rückzug des afrika korps aus el alamein
an gegen den ausdrücklichen befehl adolf
hitlers
[Musik]
eines morgens sein wie ein großes feuer
ein erkundungstrupp wurde losgeschickt
und kam mit der meldung zurück dass der
rückzug der deutschen in vollem gange
war
mit dem rückzug nach libyen verhindert
trommelt fürs erste die komplette
vernichtung des afrikakorps
aber die verluste sind enorm
[Musik]
es ist der erste große sieg der
alliierten in diesem krieg
[Musik]
shirts schilbe fehlt in großbritannien
die kirchenglocken läuten zu lassen und
während rommel sich verfolgt von den
alliierten nach westen zurück zieht
nähern sich die ersten us amerikanischen
truppen nordafrika
[Musik]
der chip bei dem ein schiff brachte die
ersten amerikanischen truppen nach
casablanca und nordafrika
erst nach drei tagen auf see wurde uns
gesagt wohin wir fuhren
wir waren die ersten us truppen die sich
hitler entgegenstellten und gegen rommel
kämpften
am 8 november startet die operation
torch die landung von us amerikanischen
und britischen truppen in nordafrika
mit den ersten strahlen kamen sie im
schlamm das ist das ermutigend
bezeichnete die wände des schicksals das
wirklich irgendwo durften
die truppen der achsenmächte stehen nun
zwischen zwei fronten müssen tobruk und
ende januar 1943 auch libyen aufgeben in
tunesien kommt es zum ersten größeren
gefecht zwischen dem afrika korps und us
truppen in der schlacht am kasserine
pass im februar 1943 fügen die
achsenmächte den amerikanern eine
schwere niederlage zu
ein soldat gibt zu wir haben einfach den
kopf verloren
perforce unteroffizier peter baxter
schreibt in sein tagebuch
die amerikaner sind schlecht auf die
schlacht vorbereitet vielleicht wissen
sie auch nicht so genau warum sie
überhaupt gegen die deutschen kämpfen
sollen
die amerikaner reagieren der front
unerfahrene befehlshaber lloyd trennen
wird abgesetzt das kommando geht an
lieutenant general george pattons die
alliierten erobern den kassen passt
zurück und schließen die truppen der
achsenmächte ein die im mai 1943
schließlich kapitulieren
der kriegseintritt der usa in nordafrika
und mehr noch die entwicklungen an der
ostfront senden starke signale es ist
jetzt ein anderer krieg
und auch im pazifik haben sich im jahr
1942 die vorzeichen des krieges
umgekehrt
menschen wie das er hatte in der regel
mehr politische macht als die marine
beide verfolgten ganz unterschiedliche
strategien
diese politische uneinigkeit hat die
japanischen kriegs anstrengungen bis
1945 beeinträchtigt
die japanische heeresführung drängt auf
die besetzung des südlichen teils von
neuguinea der flotten starb unter der
führung von admiral yamamoto plädiert
dafür gegen die amerikanische
pazifikflotte in die schlacht zu ziehen
am 18 april bekommt yamamoto zusätzliche
argumente
an diesem tag starten 16 umgerüstete b25
bombe vom flugzeugträger uss hornet zu
einem überraschungsangriff auf tokio
es ist der erste angriff auf die
japanischen heimat inseln der schaden
ist gering die psychologische wirkung
umso größer
benannt nach james doolittle dem
militärischen leiter geht die aktion als
doolittle raid in die geschichtsbücher
ein
den flugzeugen fehlt allerdings die
reichweite um zum flugzeugträger
zurückzukehren sie fliegen darum weiter
nach china als reaktion darauf erhält
japan china expeditionskorps medien
befehl die luftwaffenstützpunkte in
chiang und kern sie zu zerstören damit
die amerikaner dort in zukunft nicht
landen können es wird ein rachefeldzug
180.000 soldaten werden mobilisiert
zwischen mitte mai und anfang september
werden auf japanischer seite
36.000 auf chinesischer seite
70.000 soldaten getötet doch soldaten
sind bei weitem nicht die einzigen opfer
willing nach japan hatte offensichtlich
kein problem damit der armee freie hand
zu lassen um die zivilbevölkerung zu
terrorisieren und es hat auch keine
angst um seinen ruf in diesem modernen
krieg
eine chinesin namens chen gibt nach dem
krieg zu protokoll
in den bergen brachte eine frau ein kind
zur welt ein neugeborenes schreit
natürlich sehr laut hätten die
japanischen soldaten es gehört hätten
sie alle jungen mädchen im dorf
vergewaltigt und ermordet
es war schrecklich aber wir entschieden
uns das baby zu töten
der streit im japanischen oberkommando
endet mit einem kompromiss beide seiten
waren ihr gesicht aber die
doppelstrategie soll sich als fatal
erweisen
der vierte mai markiert den auftakt zur
schlacht im koran mehr vom
flugzeugträger uss yorktown staaten
luftangriffe gegen japanische schiffe
die auf dem weg nach port moresby sind
dem strategisch wichtigsten ort auf
neuguinea
in victorias japaner waren bis dahin bei
jedem gefecht siegreich gewesen nichts
hatte sie aufhalten können bei den
alliierten truppen hat er sich eine art
mythos entwickelt die japaner seien
unbesiegbar und nicht zu stoppen könnten
wie stop
am 7 mai orten sich die beiden flotten
gegenseitig mit aufklärungsflugzeugen
während der ganzen see schlacht werden
die feindlichen schiffe die in
sichtweite zueinander kommen
bei
der schlacht im korallen mehr mussten
die admiraner auf beiden seiten oft
innerhalb von sekundenbruchteilen
entscheiden wann sie von ihren
flugzeugträgern einen angriff starten
sollten und auch in welche richtung all
das auf grundlage unvollständiger
informationen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der amerikanische flugzeugträger
lexington wird getroffen und aufgegeben
der japanische flugzeugträger schoko
wird außer gefecht gesetzt und muss sich
zurückziehen
chicago bleibt zwar unbeschädigt
verliert aber 40 prozent ihrer flugzeuge
auch die amerikaner erleiden schwere
verluste an flugzeug
[Musik]
die letzte nachricht eines us piloten
ok macht's gut leute denkt daran wir
haben einen 1000 treffer auf den deckel
landet
[Musik]
es heißt die schlacht im korallen mehr
sei ein taktischer sieg für die japaner
gewesen
wahrscheinlich stimmt dass immerhin
versenkten sie den flugzeugträger
lexington zu einer zeit als es noch
nicht viele flugzeugträger gab aber ihre
invasions pläne mussten sie fallen
lassen in diesem sinne war es ein sieg
für die alliierten
die schlacht im koran mehr zwingt japan
die pläne für eine invasion neuguineas
vom wasser her aufzugeben und es
stattdessen über den landweg zu
versuchen
die zeit für yamamotos plan ist gekommen
die vernichtung der us marine
das soll weitere angriffe auf die
japanischen inseln unmöglich machen und
jede andere bedrohung durch die
amerikaner im pazifik ausschließen
der schauplatz des gefechts die metro
inseln westlich von hawaii
es ist der äußerste vorposten der usa im
zentralpazifik
midway wollten die japaner die us-navy
vernichten sie wollten sie in eine falle
locken und zerstören
aber der geheime plan der japaner bleibt
nicht geheim josef voß ford und sein
team von code knacken entschlüsseln
abgefangene funksprüche
die usa sind gewarnt barrel nimitz wird
roche ford später mit den worten loben
diesem offizier gebührt ein großer teil
der anerkennung für den sieg bei midway
niemitz schlägt sofort auch für einen
hochrangigen orden vor aber interne
eifersüchteleien führen dazu dass ihm
die auszeichnung erst 1985 zugesprochen
wird fast zehn jahre nach seinem tod
roush ford pflegte zu sagen
wir können alles erreichen solange es
niemanden kümmert wer die lorbeeren
erntet
[Musik]
die schlacht um midway beginnt am
vierten juni
[Musik]
admiraner komoß erste luftflotte
attackiert flugplätze und andere
einrichtungen auf den midway inseln
[Musik]
große schäden richten die japanischen
bombe aber nicht an
hat mir einer grube schließt eine zweite
angriffswelle fliegen zu lassen er
befiehlt die verbleibenden flugzeuge von
torpedos auf bomben umzurüsten
schließlich sichtet ein japanisches
aufklärungsflugzeug die amerikanische
flotte sofort lässt admiraner como die
umrüstung der flugzeuge stoppen um 10.20
gibt admiral como den einsatzbefehl nur
noch fünf minuten bis zum start der sieg
scheint zum greifen nah
doch in diesen fünf minuten wird sich
der verlauf der schlacht und es krieges
entscheidend verändern in diesen fünf
minuten greift com underweight mccluskey
vom bomben geschwader sechs der uss
enterprise mit 37 sturz kampfbombern an
die bombe rasen aus großer höhe auf die
japanischen flugzeugträger zu
der träger ag wird als erster getroffen
anschließend die kg und mit
unterstützung weiterer sturz kampfbomber
des trägers yorktown dies
später wird auch der letzte verbleibende
japanische träger die hier außer gefecht
gesetzt
die japaner verloren vier ihrer
wichtigsten flugzeugträger
wahrscheinlich vier ihrer sechs besten
mit allen flugzeugen die japanische
wirtschaft war zu klein um diese
verluste zu ersetzen
[Musik]
in wenigen minuten haben die amerikaner
das herzstück der japanischen
seestreitkräfte vernichtet
über 3000 japanische und mehr als 300 us
soldaten werden getötet
was den weiteren verlauf des krieges
angeht ist die schlacht von größter
bedeutung
die alliierten änderten jetzt ihre
einstellung und ihre strategie sie
gingen von der defensive in die
offensive
[Musik]
die nachricht aus midway wird
premierminister toyo in typisch
verklausulierter sprache zugetragen tage
tanabe schreibt ihm die marine hat einen
großen fehler begangen und admiral
montag rund 1
unsere streitkräfte erlitten einen so
entscheidenden rückschlag dass die
einzelheiten geheim gehalten wurden ein
japanischer marine kapitän in der
schlacht verwundet sagt ich hatte keinen
kontakt zur außenwelt alle verwundeten
von midway wurden so behandelt es war
als wäre man ein kriegsgefangener des
eigenen volkes
in den jahren 1943 und 44 stellen die
japanischen werften insgesamt zehn neue
flugzeugträger fertig die amerikanischen
dagegen 21 und die 200 gefallenen
japanischen elite piloten sind
unersetzlich das wichtigste an medway
ist aber nicht der sieg selbst das
wichtigste sind die konsequenzen daraus
und die sind unumkehrbar ein
flugzeugträger von denen aus
luftstreitkräfte eingesetzt werden
konnten wurden zur entscheidenden kraft
aufseher
japan hat in kürzester zeit gigantische
gebiete erobert aber sie bestehen zu
großen teilen aus wasserfläche nach der
schlacht bei midway wird aus dem pazifik
allmählich ein amerikanischer wutzler
auch an land geraten die japaner langsam
in die defensive es ist ein
schmerzhafter prozess mit vielen opfern
erster februar 1942 in singapur auf den
philippinen und in anderen ländern
südostasiens wird gekämpft
auf der insel anwohner werden zehn
australische kriegsgefangene die sich
den japanern ergeben hatten mit
bajonetten erstochen
mexiko wird ist einer der gefangenen
australier
wir waren wie lämmer die zur
schlachtbank geführt wurden wir waren
nur 1100 mann und etwa ebenso viele
niederländische harmonische soldaten
deshalb waren die kämpfe schnell vorbei
ende januar anfang februar kapitulierten
die holländer und ab da war
kriegsgefangener
bis dahin war ich keinem einzigen
japanischen soldaten begegnet
[Musik]
am 4 februar werden weitere 30
australische kriegsgefangene erstochen
oder enthauptet der dafür
verantwortliche leutnant sagt sie wurden
einer nach dem anderen zu der stelle
gebracht an der sie sterben sollten und
mussten sich mit verbundenen augen
hinknien
[Musik]
die männer traten einen nach dem anderen
aus den reihen um die gefangenen mit dem
schwert zu enthaupten oder ihnen das
bajonett in die busse zu stechen
am nächsten tag werden weitere 30
australische und niederländische
kriegsgefangene auf ähnliche weise
getötet und so geht es weiter und weiter
general thomas bley befehlshaber der
australischen truppen und ein veteran
aus dem ersten weltkrieg sagt der kampf
gegen die japaner ist nicht wie der
kampf gegen normale menschliche wesen
wir haben es nicht mit menschen zu tun
wie wir sie kennen
in der geschichte des zweiten weltkriegs
wein sich grausamkeiten wie diese
aneinander und in diesem krieg sterben
viel mehr zivilisten als soldaten
auch jenseits der schlachtfelder gibt es
unvorstellbare gewalt
[Musik]
im ghetto der weißrussischen stadt minsk
werden am 2 märz 1942 am tag des
purimfest
3412 juden von ss-leuten ermordet zwei
monate zuvor war der erste transport aus
dem polnischen ghetto litzmannstadt zum
vernichtungslager kulm hof gestartet
auch bekannt als harmlos an bord
polnische juden sowie sinti und roma
abraham goldberg war augenzeuge
sie zeigten einen quadratischen blog
abgesichert mit zusätzlichem
stacheldraht
drum herum ein zwei meter tiefer zwei
meter breiter graben
über 4000 sinti und roma werden in lkws
vergast und in den umliegenden wäldern
verscharrt
insgesamt werden rund
150.000 menschen allein in herne
ermordet die meisten von ihnen sind
juden zuletzt neun ja das war schon
damals bekannt aber das führte nicht zu
taten oder zum widerstand gegen das
regime das thema wurde damals einfach
nicht als wichtig genug angesehen
am 20 januar 1942 hatten hochrangige
nazis auf der wannseekonferenz die
logistische umsetzung der sogenannten
endlösung diskutiert und damit das
schicksal von elf millionen europäischen
juden
anwesend waren hochrangige vertreter des
ns regimes
wesentliche teile des staats und
parteiapparat werden zu komplizen des
völkermords adolf eichmann der als
leiter des sogenannten judenreferats den
systematischen massenmord koordiniert
erklärt später es ging ums töten
eliminieren und vernichten
im warschauer ghetto leben fast eine
halbe million juden eingepfercht auf
engstem raum bis die deportationen ins
vernichtungslager treblinka beginnen
sterben hier an die 100.000 menschen in
folge von hunger und krankheiten abraham
levin schreibt in sein tagebuch
aufruhr und terror sind entsetzlich
mütter verlieren ihre kinder eine
schwache alte frau muss getragen werden
der rabbiner aus der derner straße 17
wurde festgenommen genau wie kinder auf
der straße
die frage ist doch wie war es möglich
dass diese menschen deutsche mit
normalen moralvorstellungen derart
abscheuliche verbrechen begehen konnten
ohne zu begreifen oder hat seht ihr
nicht dass das menschen sind hier seht
ihr die tränen nicht
moshe fischmann gehört zu denen die in
waggons verfrachtet werden
wir mussten uns in einer reihe
aufstellen
ich wurde zur seite gestoßen meine
schwester hatte ein baby sie umklammerte
es bis zum tod wer würde das nicht tun
als abraham lewins frau mitgenommen wird
schreibt er
sonnenfinsternis universelle schwärze
meinl war wurde mitgenommen
wie kam in ihr wissen nicht genau wie
viele menschen in polen überlebt haben
es ist aber wichtig zu sagen dass viele
der überlebenden hilfe von der
polnischen bevölkerung bekamen raus
die gaskammern in treblinka werden im
sommer 1942 fertiggestellt am 23 juli
kommt der erste zug mit juden aus dem
warschauer getto an
selber schuld weil sie schossen in die
menge damit es schneller ginge
könnte sie scheuchten sie zur
bahnstrecke und fürchten sie in
viehwaggons
80 bis 100 leute nur stehplätze kein
essen kein wasser keine toilette nichts
niemand wusste wohin die reise ging
wohin brachten sie die menschen wohin
die kinder
[Musik]
das schienennetz nutzten die deutschen
mit enormer effizienz so verfrachteten
sie die juden aus allen ecken europas in
die konzentrationslager
[Musik]
der polnische dichter wurde swv
schwenkel schreibt über den falschen
bahnhof in treblinka
es gibt keinen kassierer keinen
gepäckträger nicht für eine million
bekommst du eine rückfahrkarte keiner
wartet auf dem bahnhof keiner winkt mit
einem taschentuch
nur schweigen in der luft
[Musik]
bringt der krieg böse menschen hervor
oder das böse im menschen
junge amerikanische marines auf der
salomon insel guadalcanal enthaupten
drei japanische kriegsgefangene und
stecken ihre köpfe auf pfähle ihr
kommandeur sagt ihnen sie verhielten
sich wie tiere einer der marines
antwortet
das stimmt können wir sind tiere wir
leben wie tiere wie essen und werden
behandelt wie tiere was erwarten sie
denn
[Musik]
die salomonen eine strategisch wichtige
inselgruppe mit knapp 1000 inseln liegen
vor dem nord ost kap australiens
die japaner nennen die hauptinsel gar
der eu carraro die amerikaner schlicht
kaktus tatsächlich heißt sie guadalcanal
[Musik]
der kanal war der erste echte tiefschlag
für die japaner in diesem krieg hätten
sie besser aufgepasst wären ihre
befehlshaber strategisch geschickter
gewesen dann hätten sie die insel besser
befestigt bevor die amerikaner kamen
die japanischen truppen waren im april
1942 auf der südsee insel gelandet
während des japanischen vormarschs im
westlichen pazifik
am 5 juni hatte der us geheimdienst die
information erhalten dass die japaner
auf guadalcanal einen
luftwaffenstützpunkt bauen damit bekommt
die insel eine neue strategische
bedeutung
ein traum wäre auf diesem flugplatz
wollten sie flugzeuge stationieren deren
reichweite die gesamten salomonen-inseln
und dass korallen mehr weiter im süden
abgedeckt hätte
am siebten august landen die
amerikanischen streitkräfte auf gerader
kanal es ist ihre erste landung im
pazifik überhaupt auf einer insel deren
name für immer in die amerikanische
geschichte eingehen wird
sie stoßen auf wenig widerstand
innerhalb von zwei tagen bringen die usa
rund 19.000 marineinfanteristen an land
die japanischen streitkräfte knapp 2200
mann und hauptsächlich bauarbeiter sind
völlig überrascht sie ziehen sich in die
berge zurück
da in der händler sind flugplatz benannt
nach einem marine piloten der in der
schlacht von midway gefallen ist wurde
am achten august eingenommen
[Musik]
die amerikaner haben die japaner von
einem wichtiges sprungbrett nach spanien
vertrieben
doch die freude ist zu früh in der nacht
nach der landung stellt ein japanischer
flottenverband aus sieben kräutern und
einem zerstörer die alliierten
streitkräfte
schauplatz der 15 kilometer breite kanal
zwischen nadal kanal und sutherland
die japaner versenkten zusammen vier
amerikanische und australische kreuzer
1024 alliierte seeleute und 69
japanische soldaten sterben nach der
schlacht von iwo island zieht sich die
us-marine erst einmal zurück die landung
truppen auf guadalcanal bleiben vorerst
ohne unterstützung
die wohnungshaltung nach erfolgreicher
inversion trotz japanischer gegenwehr
dass er über territorium
am 18 august bekommen die japaner auch
noch verstärkung
in einem bericht schwärmt ein
marinesoldat der sich der insel näherte
von der üppigen idylle die sich immer
mehr aus bot
die insel später verließ bezeichnete er
sie nur noch als grüne hölle
in einem japanischen schriftstück heißt
es erfolg oder misserfolg bei der
rückeroberung von guadalcanal sei die
weggabelung auf der straße zum sieg
am 21 august schlagen die japaner zu sie
greifen nachts an denn sie halten die
amerikaner für weichlinge die nicht
gerne im dunkeln kämpfen viele
einzelheiten des gefechts sind bis heute
unklar oder umstritten das ergebnis
jedoch nicht die amerikanischen verluste
sind gering die japanischen dagegen
immens der japanische kommandeur oberst
cicek ii nimmt sich nach der schlacht
das leben
[Musik]
der sieg hebt die kampfmoral der
amerikaner die japaner sind auch an land
zu schlagen
marinesoldat will i am happy schreibt in
sein tagebuch
im radio sagen sie dass die schlacht vom
freitag das größte gemetzel der
geschichte war
[Musik]
ein lied das japanische soldaten auf dem
weg zum schlachtfeld singen hat diesen
text über
das meer leichen im wasser über den berg
leichen auf dem feld nur für den kaiser
werde ich sterben ich werde nie
zurückblicken
im dezember 1942 erklärt general tokio
equipe seit oktober 1941 auch
japanischer premierminister
unser reich steht an der schwelle
zwischen rom und untergang
die schlacht um guadalcanal dauert bis
zur endgültigen evakuierung der insel
durch die japaner anfang februar 1943
insgesamt werden rund 7000 amerikaner
getötet während über 20.000 japaner um
kommen im kampf aber auch durch
krankheiten
0 75 prozent der japanischen verluste
waren keine direkten folgen der schlacht
selbst die erste us marine division
hatte über 10.000 verluste davon etwa
1500 im gefecht die restlichen durch
krankheiten
[Musik]
schlimmer kann online anbieter und
blutig der weg ist dennoch schon ihnen
liegt der weg nach tokio
die schlacht im koran mehr hat die
japanischen pläne durchkreuzt die
einnahme von port moresby der hauptstadt
papua neuguineas über den seeweg ist vom
tisch
in port moresby war wichtig die japaner
wollten dort ihre südliche
verteidigungslinie festigen außerdem
hätten sie von da aus die städte im
norden australiens angreifen und die
handelt verbindung zwischen australien
und den usa kappen können
die alternative zu einer landung von
truppen per schiff ist der angriff von
der landseite aber dafür müssen die
soldaten zuerst das anständige bürger
überqueren das gelände war entscheidend
dass gewaltigen stanley gebirge
bestimmte in vielerlei hinsicht dem
kampf in coco da
ein australischer offizier beschreibt
das terra ganz einfach so berge berge
berge und noch mehr berge furchtbar
[Musik]
ein flugfeld in buna an der nordküste
von neuguinea general douglas macarthur
alliierter befehlshaber im westpazifik
will es sich für künftige operationen
sichern im juli wird eine kleine
australische truppe von port moresby aus
losgeschickt um nach bona zu marschieren
die rote trägt den namen eines kleinen
dorfes entlang der strecke coco da
[Musik]
in dieser region gab es kaum
infrastruktur auf der ecoc oder route
konnten keine lastwagen fahren um die
soldaten zu versorgen alles musste
getragen werden
ein japanisches vorauskommando unter
oberst yusuke yokoyama landet am 21 juli
an der nordküste die japaner marschieren
auf die ahnungslosen und zahlenmäßig
weit unterlegenen australier zu
sie wollten auf der kokon der route
genau die gleiche taktik anwenden die
schon in britische maria erfolgreich
gewesen war die soldaten sollten mit
fahrrädern durch den dschungel fahren
nur schätzen die japaner das gelände
völlig falsch ein
am 23 juli kommt es zur ersten
feindberührung
[Musik]
aus dem tagebuch eines australiens
nachdem left and körner lohnen so viele
vorräte materialien und gebäude in cocoa
wie möglich zerstört hatte zog er sich
mit seinen truppen zurück
es ist der beginn eines umkämpften
rückzugs der australier nach port
moresby
doch im september wendet sich das blatt
der alliierten bekommen verstärkung
während die versorgungslage der japaner
immer schlechter wird
es regnete in strömen eine lange reihe
runde mühler männer mühte sich ab
verwundete den berg runter zu bringen
für die japaner ist es der anfang vom
ende
einladungs versuch von zusätzlichen
truppen wird zurückgeschlagen zum ersten
mal überhaupt scheitert eine japanische
landung vom wasser aus
sie kamen und stellten ein
maschinengewehr neben einem baum auf
sobald der schütze getötet wurde nahm
ein anderer seinen platz ein so ging das
stundenlang
der sohn von jemandem der vater von
jemandem der ehemann von jemandem
[Musik]
am 2 januar 1943 feld buna an die
alliierten
[Musik]
sie haben dem tod ins auge gesehen und
lächeln trotzdem noch aber sie wissen
auch der kampf gegen japan fängt gerade
erst an
der pazifik rieck tobt auf dem meer und
im dschungel und in europa beginnt ende
juni 1942 hitlers fall blau die
sommeroffensive der wehrmacht in der
sowjetunion
[Musik]
mit 19 als das wetter besser wurde die
straßen wieder befahrbar waren und die
steppe trocken starteten die deutschen
ihre große offensive
3 way auf guadalcanal und in neuguinea
gewinnen langsam aber sicher die
alliierten die oberhand im pazifik
gleichzeitig setzt das deutsche reich
alles daran den zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion zu erzwingen koste es was es
wolle